is live and uncensored so come on what
is a woman well I mean a woman is
whatever JK Rowling says a woman is
right and she's right a woman is a
biological human female
how on Earth have we got to a place
we're stating that simple fact has now
become a stick to beat people with when
from what I can ascertain 99 of the
entire planet agrees with that fact yep
again it goes back to that idea that
your subjective feeling about yourself
must be reflected by the rest of the
world cheered and celebrated by the rest
a little because that's that's actually
what the ask is right the ask isn't even
you know I wish to be treated well in
society and you can think whatever you
want of me but you should treat me
decently that's not the actual ass the
actual ask is I wish for you to
participate in age illusion whereby I am
a biological human female or exactly the
same in many important respects as a
biological human female trans women are
women which again if you refuse to find
one about this and I've warned about it
and we've taken it to we said in the
warnings if you take this to a logical
conclusion it's going to get abused and
we had a stark example of this in
Scotland several weeks ago with this
rapist Adam Graham who at his child
having raped two women with his penis
and let's be her penis well this is the
point he then turned up as Isla Bryson
and said I'm now a woman so that's him
before and then he comes along as Isla
Bryce there and the the game plan
according to his ex-wife is what he just
wants to get into a women's prison which
is obviously what his game plan was and
he got into one uh put into a woman's
prison where there are women there who
are vulnerable to attacks from people
like him
um that to me showed the insanity of
this well a leader Nicholas sturgeon
been leader of Scotland for eight years
who've supported this Limitless gender
identity nonsense and lost her job
actually I think it was a direct
consequence of this yeah I mean see what
she said I'll play it to you
the question is are all trans women
women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with yeah trans women are
women but in the present context there
is no automatic right for a trans woman
there are context where our trans women
is not a woman no there is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate
I think that interview Costa her job
because when I watched that it went on
for about 50 seconds it was jaw-dropping
because actually her ideology about this
was it was just cruelly exposed as being
completely ridiculous well it's an
Emperor's New Clothes kind of thing and
again when that happens to politicians
who are supposed to supposedly traffic
in fact it makes it very difficult for
them and so when you take a completely
logically unsustainable position like
trans women are women but some of those
women are going to be housed with the
man which is what she does In that clip
everybody can see how ridiculous it is
and it exposes the ideology for what it
is which is baseless and and nonsense
and and extraordinarily negative because
again if you undermine societal
perceptions of Truth we're supposed to
be living in this terrible time of
immisinformation and disinformation I
can't think of anything worse in terms
of misinformation than the idea that a
biological man is in fact a female and
when you see what's happening in sport
it's even more absurd where you see six
foot three inch swimmers formerly male
swimmers dominating the women's sport
and you think well where does this leave
woman sport if you just allow others to
continue ultimately women's sport will
get dismissed honestly the most
frightening part of this to me is not
even sort of the direct consequences of
this and some of it is directed at kids
right I mean we are teaching kids in the
United States who are five six seven
years old about gender fluidity about
how boys can become girls which kids are
vulnerable kids need to be protected
from nonsense and kids actually need
rules and expectations and and basically
saying to them that you can be a member
of the opposite sex is insane and what
we've seen predictably enough from young
people from teenagers is a radical
skyrocketing increasing rate of people
who are identifying as trans or gender
non-binary and then not shockingly at
the exact same time a rapid rise in
suicidal ideation and depression and
confusion none of that is a shock this
is all a social contagion there's never
been anything of the Tavistock Clinic
here yes in London which you know anyone
who raised any concerns about this was
mutually branded transphobic which put
people off raising concerns but it
turned out 97 of the young kids that
were sent there for this gender
reassignment turned out to have other
issues from autism to depression 97 and
what they really needed was an adult to
be adult about this and say well before
we irrevocably change
your body and cut you to pieces we're
actually going to have a proper
conversation about these other issues
you've got right exactly but but yeah
again I think this is part of a broader
attack on the notion of truth and the
attack on institutions is is really what
it what it is in the end because the
question is why is it so important to
teach kids who are five six seven years
old about being gender non-binary or or
trans again there is an actual condition
called gender dysphoria or gender
identity disorder and some people suffer
from it it's a very small percentage of
the population it is not 30 40 20 10 5
of the population but it does exist
obviously and those people are suffering
and we should try to find ways to to
help them whether that is in the medical
context with regard to therapy or
whether we're talking about you know
just families treating them well but
that that is not the same thing as
indoctrinating entire generations of
people and forcing all of society to go
along with it I mean this is the real
issue right you're asking all of society
to tell a lie in the name of sensitivity
well once you've done that with any
issue you can do that with pretty much
every issue well we saw it with the
ridiculous fast of the Roald Dahl but
all having this sensitivity reading at
first moving hundreds and hundreds of
words and phrases from this from this
you know iconic authors through southern
300 million books suddenly they're
rewriting this stuff and some of the
rewrites were so completely ridiculous
one where attractors are referred to as
black they had to change that because
somehow you can't have a black tractor
but what if the tractor's black one of
the real problems here is that the
modern context cannot understand why
kids would read Roald Dahl that really
is the major issue right I re-rolled all
of my kids I just got through I think
pretty much his entire corpus with my
six-year-old and extraordinary books
kids love it because the books are mean
because the books are yes right the
books are about be life is a rough place
where people are mean to you and social
expectations are set for you and people
will talk to you which is great
preparation for what the actual world is
like correct words of them whereas now
you move to a place where even egg and
Spoon races have been banned in England
for example at schools because they
encourage too much aggression amongst
the kids who want to win he's like well
where does that leave you then so kids
get taught everybody wins you will get a
participation prize once you have that
mindset where's the preparation for the
real that's right well it's a war
against reality and the reality is that
for example in Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory being fat is not as good for you
as not being fat right if you're
Augustus Gloop it turns out that you
probably shouldn't overeat but this is
considered mean so we're just going to
cut the word fast but the reader the
sensitivity reader said it's enormous
right yes it couldn't be fat but it
could be enormous what are you talking
about you can't wipe that away but again
I think that's setting up a predicate
for a broader ideological shift which is
any problems you experience in your life
are through no volition of your own or
any action of your own you're not
responsible for your own actions Society
at large is responsible for your actions
for setting up unrealistic standards of
beauty or Society is responsible for
setting up some sort of sensitivity to
you as a human being what about the
damage it's done for example I think a
lot of damage to being male being a man
being masculine that everything is now
characterized as toxic masculinity
absolutely I mean the the
effect on men and by the way by proxy on
women because it turns out that women
actually kind of like masculine medicine
all of human procreation is rooted in
this essential biological fact the the
destruction of men in the west is the
great story of the last 40 years which
is men basically
somehow got the paper the patriarchy was
so clever that they somehow convinced
women that sexual Liberation was
actually the most wonderful thing for
women but as it turns out it actually
backfired and it ended up destroying men
because men do need marriage men need
roles men need actual things to do in
the course of their lifetime and the
thing that most men did for virtually
all of human history was get married
have kids protect and defend your your
wife and kids that was the role and you
were trained to do this from the time
that you were a small kid it's what you
know I have three kids going on for I
train my kids to do this now I talk to
them about how many kids do you want to
have what kind of job do you want to
have how do you want to bring up those
kids they're small you train kids to be
adults because you know what kids want
they want to be adults and what they
want is a path from how I get to point a
being a child to being an adult but we
as a society have completely destroyed
that path because we've said that adult
Ting is now number one a verb and number
two we've said that being an adult is is
somehow no longer required of you
Society is going to take care of you no
matter what problem you have it's it's
everybody else's job to fix all of them
people like Andrew Tate got such
traction yes so what I've said about
Andrew Tate is that I would say that 75
of Andrew Tate's diagnoses of the
problem are pretty correct yeah I agree
and then I would say that a lot of his
prescriptions are completely wrong yeah
right so so he will he will say men have
lost their role in the world and then
what he will model is cam girls it's
like well that's not actually the
solution but what you're saying about
the problem of men losing their role and
Men needing to be masculine and Men
needing to want to win and Men needing
to cultivate an ability to to go out and
succeed and thrive in the world all of
that is 100 true I just think that he
himself on a personal level wasn't
providing a model of that to me a model
of that is a guy who is married who has
kids who lives in the community who
betters the community lives in who hires
people creates a business like these are
the things that historically speaking
did Define manhood and now they no
longer Define manhood men I think that
you can shot at the moment of
deterioration for the moment James Bond
suddenly crying it's like you know you
take even that take even bonded
emasculating it's like he has to be in
touch with his feelings why why can't he
just shoot people and drink martinis and
seduce women and what's wrong with that
right well that is again a cultural move
and you're right against masculinity and
in pretty much every sphere and the
conflation of masculinity which is good
with toxic masculine that all
masculinity is bad so we need to
feminize Society overall we don't need
to feminize Society overall any more
than we need to masculinize society
overall what we need is for men to be
men and women to be women that doesn't
mean that women are barefoot and
pregnant in the kitchen as I've said
many times my wife is a doctor right
what it does mean is that there are
essential qualities to being a woman
that are different from many of the
essential qualities to being a man he's
not important here's one part of all
this debate which I disagree with you
about so you you don't agree with gay
marriage or with gay parenting I don't
want to miss quite yes I think that's
your position now I would say that
reading the rest of your views on stuff
you're very about fairness and equality
for all right how does that fit in there
why shouldn't two men who are gay
actually be able to bring a child up why
shouldn't they who want to get married
how is it equal fair for them to be
excluded so we can take those issues one
by one so marriage is a societal
institution the question is which
relationships Society chooses to
sanctify so I'm not in favor of for
example laws that criminalize homosexual
activity or two men living together or
two men making a lifelong commitment to
one another in whatever context they
wish to do that what I'm objecting to is
the idea that marriage as a term is
equally applicable to relationships that
are designed to produce the future
generation and then raise them as
opposed to two people who love each
other the fundamental redefinition of
marriage actually happened before
same-sex marriage within heterosexual
marriage away from the purpose of
heterosexual marriage is man woman child
to two people who love each other once
you do that then that obviously is going
to Encompass things like two men or two
women but it has no limiting principle
because then it could be any group of
people who love each other and I don't
think that the government has a
fundamental role in in propagating
relationships other than ones that have
externalities that that benefit society
and the chief externality that benefit
Society from marriage is having children
and children raised largely with their
biological parents as far as gay
parenting what I've said is that they're
sort of hierarchies of options meaning
that the ideal is man woman child and
then you know if you can't fulfill that
ideal then there's obviously
degradations I'd rather that two gay men
are raising a child then have that child
be in an orphanage for example so it's
not as though the alternatives are
always you know the ones that I would
want but shouldn't they be allowed to
have the same just rights in law to what
straight couples would have well I mean
it's more benefits than rights right if
you're talking about it right what
you're talking about is a government
non-intervention with particular
activity now when it comes to children
we obviously do things to protect
children engaged parents who are
fantastic parents I've seen gay parents
where they are not fantastic parents
sure I've seen a lot of straight parents
who are awful and I've seen some great
straight Pro I don't really see any
particular distinction about what
combination you have as your past so I
do and the reason I do is because again
I think there is a fundamental
distinction between woman and man and
what that means is that mothers and
fathers are both necessary and so the
idea that two men can simply supplant a
man and a woman in a generic average
level I don't think Insurance what
they're doing they are this is what they
I mean you don't think that gay people
become gay presumably right well I mean
I think that the the notion that that
everyone who is gay was always gay from
the time that they were born I don't
think that the data back that per se
because we are seeing Rising levels for
example across Society of people
identifying in a particular way so there
is some fluidity to sexual behavior and
sexual activity there's less fluidity
probably to sexual orientation I assume
that the majority yeah
gay people male and female are are born
gay right if you take that as a basic
premise majority which I I absolutely
believe I'm just not sure how
it's fair or Equitable to deny them the
same rights to their relationship status
or to Parenting that you would give to
straight people so again I really don't
think that has anything to do with being
born or not born in a particular way I
think even if they were not born in a
particular way that the government
should not criminalize private activity
what I do think is that if we're talking
about the benefits that a government is
giving in order to propagate child
bearing and rearing within the context
of the biological parents which is again
what marriage originally was supposed to
be which is why marriage was government
sponsored what would you do if one of
you no idea but if one of your kids
turned out to be gay and wanted to get
married would you be tough on tough
enough to say you can't do that I mean I
would oppose that from so religion so
again marriage existence religious yeah
religion so so marriage exists in a
couple of different iterations one is
religious marriage which is kind of what
I care about and then there is
governmental sanctioned marriage which
is a public policy question right when
it comes to religious marriage no I I'm
not in favor of My Religion sanctifying
same-sex couple specifically because
again my religion propagates the idea
that man woman and child is the model
for family